there is the now third year head coach
of the Los Angeles chargers couple of
strong seasons to get his coaching
career started he's Anthony Lane coach
welcome back to the program how are you
I'm doing fine how you guys doing oh
we're doing great we're doing great
coach of the year you and you know what
he's not just saying that go to the he
he does panders to everybody else but he
was arguing for you to be coach of the
year back at the end of the season yeah
you the man I mean but coach Boatshed
gets my vote I feel like he's like Bron
James Michael Jordan think where you can
go I think he can win the MVP every year
I mean it is pretty remarkable right it
really is just watching greatness right
now yeah
what did you learn going against him or
you know through the years and even of
course in the divisional playoff game
you know being in that division you know
you learn a lot going against them and
how they win and we were playing them
again tomorrow
you know we'd probably play them a
little differently right right I don't
want to talk about what we would do
differently right now yeah but I mean
they're really good at uh just being
very gameplan specific you know they
come out each week with a different game
plan their players are very smart they
can adapt and in the shows they got the
best quarterbacks they played the game
yeah yeah you guys had an amazing season
this year away from Los Angeles
undefeated in every game that wasn't
played in LA except that last game is
there something about playing in New
England something about Gillette Stadium
or was it just the opponent that day no
you know they are tough to beat at home
they have some some record and had me
beat at home in a while and playoffs but
they were just tough to beat that day
you know that they were more prepared
than we were and I mean I guys they
worked hard we we met we did all the
things we've been doing but they made
the plays we did they jumped out on us
35 to 70 first half the second half we
came back we got scoring 21 to 6 but we
made some adjustments but it's a little
too late you were you you know you were
second best record in the AFC are you
one of those guys cuz I mean oh there
was people arguing out there that all
they need to you know fix this reseeding
thing it's not fair that you know you
got to go on the road the first week and
you got the second best record in the
conference are you good with it being
status quo you know I'm fine with its
status quo I mean you win your division
and you do have a home game so we had a
chance to win on division you know it
slipped away from us yeah it's a tough
division I did say that
tough division going forward and you had
to
Patrick mahomes this year you beat him
in his own building but what what was
your impression of him from the
standpoint of seeing film and getting
ready to face a guy like that live in a
game twice this year I tell you I any
read in the enemy did a heck of a job I
mean I knew he was heck of a football
player but I didn't see this coming so
soon and the things he did on the
football field this year was just
unbelievable watching that young man
play how much more prepared were you the
second time around cuz you guys were the
first victims of mahomes mainly a weak
one right out of the gates and everybody
wakes up to him the second time around
what was different for you after being
able to study a full season well just
having time to say the whole team they
have weapons everywhere yeah you know
entire week and in the tidy and kelsey
so we just know we had a better plan you
know they did jump out on this way to
come back from behind and win that game
right but uh I guess they just played
hard we executed down the stretch and
now we didn't turn the ball over yeah
that was key for us how about players
playing basketball how do you feel about
that Thurman James given the tomahawk
slams which is actually an unbelievable
pretty nice I mean I would give it a ten
right you know you know you asking most
motorcycles basketball you know you know
some guys do that for charity they're
raising money for great calls but just
to go out and just to do it you know
what we'll talk about it yeah I talked
about DJ but we have to be careful you
will be you'll say something oh yeah you
don't want them to do it at all I guess
it's really the day yeah I get it I was
in Denver right skiing yeah yeah I know
I hear you I don't know how to ski
because of that I grew up in that kind
of household yeah so but with basketball
with basketball right so many guys
played in the offseason as a way to stay
in shape where does the balance between
keeping your guys in shape and knowing
that they're out there doing something
other than sitting on their butts
watching TV and eating pizza you know a
lot of things you can do besides sitting
on your bus getting ready but uh
basketball it is one of those sports
that will keep you in good shape I used
to play it on time I loved basketball
but at the same time we have to be
careful because you know if you go out
and you turn a co something
then you know you missed the whole year
and you just have to sit down and
splaining that to you young players but
um that's all yeah I don't wanna make
too big of a deal yeah no I hear ya I
hear ya how about your your quarterback
Phillip Rivers how many years do you
think he's got left in him I don't know
yeah you know I thought he looked better
than 218 into 17 right I'm talking about
from a movement and just strength of
form sure so I think I got better
yeah so I you know if you just continue
that trend who knows
do you ever tell him to move closer like
does he enjoy doing these two hour
drives each way every day you know I
drove I work for the Cowboys I drove an
hour and 15 minutes of work every single
day Wow my kids could go to my high
school right okay and so his his ride is
about an hour 30 and when you look at
his mobile office the work that he's
getting done while he's in the vehicle
yeah it's really impressive yeah coach
it's amazing you say that he seemed
physically better this year because he's
in that sweet spot where he's seen it
all so you become essentially the
offensive coordinator on the field
because there's nothing they can show
you you haven't seen and it's a question
of hanging on physically once you get to
that point where you can look across the
line and know it's coming if you're
actually getting better then who knows
he may have several years left in the
tank you know that's what I'm saying I
mean look at Brady he raised 41 years
old I mean from from my view he looked
like a 21 year old Yeah right no but uh
yeah but I feel I mean not turning the
ball over he played at a Pro Bowl level
he's moving around in the pocket he's
escaping he's throwing under I mean he
just he looked good yeah he's a baller
and then I gotta take him to my first
year here I'm watching him practice and
there were some times I'm thinking we
gotta start looking for down the road
for the next guy right but that never
crossed my mind this year right well
what is what would be your preference
just along these same converse this
conversation of would you rather would
you rather have a quarterback and draft
him at some point here during the Philip
Rivers tenure to where he gets a year
behind Philip or do you not worry about
that and just go when Philips done then
we'll figure it out from there you know
we have Cordell Jones on the roster
right now Gino is an unrestricted free
right sure yet
but whoever we bring in sitting behind
full of rivers I mean it's an advantage
for them yeah because he can teach them
so much about being a professional
quarterback in this league yeah what's
the one thing about combine week that
you look the most forward to just the
first exposure you know getting to see
the guys you watch them on tape you come
here and see if they do anything to
validate what you saw on tape you know
you meet them you watch them compete and
work out of it what about when you get
them in the interview room with them
what what's your style and strategy to
get through whatever preparation because
they all have preparation now they all
know what they're supposed to do you
bust through that and get to the real
guy you know you have to be careful
busting through that to get to the real
guy because he may ask a question that's
not appropriate
now right and so uh you know I think you
see that happening every year but you
you really want to pick his brain to see
what he knows football wise and just see
where he's at football IQ wise can he
learn how fast you learn what does he
know I get to know them when I go see
them I go visit a guy in this College
well I take them to dinner at some point
he lets his guards down and then you
really get to know the young man yeah
yeah Hoosiers you like that movie okay I
would you kiss the bricks on the ground
if you won the Indy 500 would you do
that you would say yes to both of those
really no not everyone's gonna say yes
the Hoosiers I know a lot of people that
think Hoosiers is overrated so I want to
make sure I got some great movie that's
a great movie okay I just want to make
sure how much you looking forward to
getting into a new stadium getting away
from that 30,000 seat soccer stadium you
guys are playing oh I've gone down I've
taken the coaches to see the new stadium
it's offseason I'm gonna take the
players down to see it it's an iconic
stadium can't wait to get there but
right now I mean the place we're playing
right now is you can't watch he asked
for a better place for watching NFL
football game you know you know some
people may never have not a fantasy yeah
right it's not a bad seat in the house
yeah there's something about LA though
and I think it's because there was no
team there for 20 years so you have
pockets of fans that have gravitated
around all the other teams so when other
it's the Rams of the charge you guys
have a home game you have to worry about
the fans of these other teams who are in
LA because there was no team there for
20 years flooding the stadium you see
that and and I think la is a great place
to visit if you if you're coming from
Philadelphia for example you know if
you're gonna go watch our team play kind
of weight is not a bad place to go
question play you got great weather you
got beaches so you get some of that you
got some young personalities on your
team pretty cool like ASAP right ASAP
which is Melvin Ingram any squad any
place how did that kind of come about
was that a was a you know coach thing or
did the players kind of come up with
that
Melvin probably came up he is on music
we come out in our pregame we come out
in pre practice sometimes we'll play
some of Melvin's music you know he
recourse in Florida it is that right
it's not bad so you're okay with music
at practice because we've come across
the coaches who were like oh he's
reluctant ly embrace but he said he told
us going around teams doing TV work this
year he realized a lot of people play
music so he's gonna try to infuse that
into so that's what you'll use we use
that for crowd noise like to prepare for
that sometimes we'll use music for crowd
right yeah right right and you guys like
this just brings a little more energy to
practice yeah how Bosa okay I mean him
and Ingram how do they feed off each
other because I just think they're I
mean both it seems quiet and reserved he
really is but that is a unique
friendship man those guys they they love
one another they play hard for one
another and root for one another there's
no Envy there on who gets this sack yeah
I would not know joy he goes to Pro Bowl
actually he steps back that's Melvin
replace him but those guys I mean they
it's really neat to see them compete but
poor for one another same time yeah yeah
you know I know injuries aren't an
excuse but do you ever catch yourself
wondering if we could just get one of
these years where we just get lucky and
everybody stays healthy the sky's the
limit for this team you know yeah you
love to see you guys stay healthy
absolutely but you know around the
league's you know there's injuries
everywhere so you can you definitely
can't use it as an excuse but we always
have to be prepared for when guy goes
down next man up mentality and I thought
this year I guys had an outstanding job
of next man up next man up especially on
the defense side of all right at one
time we lost five key starters
now you can tell it ya know it's it's an
impressive team and last question before
we let you go just like how about your
the the rebound effort you know you get
to see this Lamar Jackson this running
game everything and then you get your
first playoff win off of that I mean
just what was that like and what was
that like facing that defense or that
offense for the second time you know we
the more you see that you know I think
the better you get because you don't see
that type of office every single week
Christy right and it really caught us
off guard the first time and we didn't
have a lot of time to prepare for work
yeah right it was a Saturday night game
Friday night yeah so we would definitely
more prepare it in the playoff game yeah
well hey coach we're big fans of what
you're doing we think you're one of the
best coaches in the NFL already after
only a couple of seasons and we believe
the sky's the limit and we look forward
to watching you reach for those Heights
appreciate all right look forward to
talking to you soon thanks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports